[Música]
bienvenidos a en 5 minutos con nos
acompaña edison lanza relator especial
para la libertad de expresión de la
comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos señor edison lanza gracias por
esta comunicación comenzó en francia el
juicio contra los presuntos cómplices
del ataque terrorista de 2015 al
semanario charlie hebdo que continuó con
una serie de asaltos que dejaron 17
muertos ataques motivados por la
publicación de una caricatura de mahoma
cinco años después se reaviva el debate
sobre la libertad de expresión deben los
medios manejar una libertad total en sus
publicaciones y si no es así como
deberían tratarse esas líneas que
definan los límites para ellas buenos
días sí yo creo que digamos la
protección que la libertad de expresión
ofrece especialmente a determinados
discursos tiene que ver con el interés
público de esa información y en este
sentido los estándares internacionales
digamos no excluyen a ningún sector ni
político ni religioso ni de otro índole
social éste verá crítica de la
información o de ser objeto digamos de
información y por eso los relatores de
libertad de expresión hemos dicho ya
desde hace años este que por ejemplo
delitos como la blasfemia u otros que
protegen especialmente a una religión
determinada son incompatibles con la
libertad de expresión porque bueno
impiden a esa comunidad religiosa
digamos estar fuera del escrutinio o
estar a más perdón impiden que estén
bajo el escrutinio y la verdad es que
son también además de obviamente la
libertad de culto que no pueden ejercer
con total plenitud este también son un
grupo digamos de algún modo de poder que
está
el escrutinio y este de los medios de
comunicación es en ese sentido no hay un
límite penal obviamente si el medio de
comunicación afirma algo que es
abiertamente falso sobre un líder
religioso subir que más está bajo las
mismas reglas de las responsabilidades
ulteriores que tienen que ver con
responsabilidades civiles estándar de
real malicia eventualmente derecho de
respuesta etcétera no señor félix o
nathan debería protegerse más
rigurosamente los temas políticos o
religiosos que otras formas de expresión
bueno estaba vinculado con lo que dije
anteriormente creo que lo que se protege
básicamente es la función social y
democrática que cumple con la libertad
de expresión para cualquier sociedad
abierta y plural lo que sucede es que
algunas de las sociedades en el mundo
que son confesionales o sea que el
estado
adopta una religión en no son sociedades
abiertas y plurales entonces protegen su
religión protegen su comunidad de
valores religiosos y en una sociedad
democrática bueno incluso las
confesiones religiosas están bajo
escrutinio crítica e incluso sátira este
porque bueno de lo que se trata es de
que haya un libre flujo de información
de ideas y de escrutinio sobre los
distintos poderes que actúan en la
sociedad estamos en una era digital
señor ellos son lanza la llegada de
estas nuevas tecnologías traspasa
fronteras ha cambiado esto la forma en
que se debe responder a las preguntas
sobre la libertad de expresión
yo creo que algunas preguntas nos están
cambiando cuando teníamos las respuestas
nos cambiaron las preguntas hay alguien
que decía no y creo que efectivamente
por ejemplo cuando se inyecta
desinformación de manera deliberada para
distorsionar una elección para o sobre
kobe 19 por ejemplo ahora en el marco de
la pandemia por un grupo o por un actor
político geopolítico estamos un poco
fuera del ámbito del debate justo del
debate abierto y esto se suma a la
viralización que tiene hoy internet y la
posibilidad de que una desinformación
deliberada por ejemplo circule
rápidamente por la red y contamine el
debate público etcétera porque la idea
de la democracia es que las ideas
equivocadas o no fluyan en el ámbito
público se debatan se discutan y se
puedan y se puedan tomar decisiones por
parte de las personas por parte de los
ciudadanos ahora cuando hay alguien que
dice algo o inyecta algo deliberado crea
un medio falso para la falsedad
este en general y digamos cuando es
deliberada es un problema sin duda no
muy bien pues muchas gracias señor
edison lanza por esta comunicación y por
su análisis el relator especial para la
libertad de expresión de la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos a
ustedes les agradecemos mucho su
compañía los invitamos a que sigan con
nosotros con más mucho más aquí en
france24 punto com
[Música]